i want to do a semi-hard segue to this
story from fox news brooklyn subway
shooting person of interest frank james
posted racist rants to youtube for years
i do believe he got arrested and what
i've heard and i think you know i
thought to jason to correct me if i'm
wrong is that this guy was posting like
black nationalist stuff yes
he's been
radicalized by corporate media we've
been sending
black people the message through
corporate media that
you're a victim you're oppressed
white people are the devil
uh and this guy bought what the media
was selling he's from milwaukee or
waukesha same area as the darrell brooks
guy who was radicalized
uh this
it's no one should be surprised that
we're creating these types of monsters
uh because the media is basically
telling you're crazy if you don't think
like this guy i got i got a story for
you jason some people watch the show and
have seen it may have heard me but um i
assume most people haven't heard the
story i i know sometimes i tell stories
you know several times but there's
different guests i apologize for it but
i knew a guy once and uh
i'll try and simplify the story for the
sake of their privacy there's a black
dude and there was a white dude and the
black dude mentioned he was gonna you
know
go run to the store real quick and the
white dude said hey when you're out can
you mine you know when you buy the store
can you grab me a cheeseburger from the
mcdonald's and the guy said excuse me
and he was like
would you mind grabbing me a
cheeseburger when you're over there by
the mcdonald's and then he started
yelling at him like what do you think
who do you think i am
later the you know i asked the guy like
whoa i saw you yelling like what
happened and he's like the dude he
thinks i'm his boy like i'm gonna go and
get him food and then i was like
i
if you were going to the store i figured
he'd just ask you to pick him up a
burger and so that was to me i was kind
of like yo i was like i think you might
be looking too much into this and he
said you don't understand man you don't
understand what they think about people
like me
and then i was like when i was growing
up
it didn't matter what your race were
we'd be like oh hey you're out hey give
me a hot dog and fries would you do it
we'd be like sure
but i think what happens is you have
people constantly saying
you know it's like ibra max kennedy said
it's not a question of did racism happen
it's how did racism manifest you'll have
people who who think it's everywhere and
look for it and i'm like
maybe maybe he just wanted you to be his
friend and you know do him a favor maybe
he wasn't being racist but if people
internalize that and they they
constantly look for it they might get
offended where they shouldn't
this goes all the way back to the
feminization of america
everything's about
feelings women
are
driven by feelings more so than men
we've turned this entire society about i
feel like a woman even though i have a
penis i feel like
something was racist even though that
coach called
a white guy mf and that's his language
of choice even though that same guy that
asked to get a cheeseburger asked his
white friend to get him a cheeseburger
the week before but if i feel like it
was racist
it is
and we all
seem to accept that standard i don't
personally but
growing up uh
you know i had friends who would use
racial slurs for all of us
and
he he wasn't racist
he was just
it was just edgy young punk humor we
watched family guy in south park so he'd
go around and we'd all laugh at it he
would he would you know call us names
i'm like i don't care like because he's
my friend and i know he's he's just
trying to you know take take jabs at me
and it's funny and he would call himself
names too but today's day and age it's
like
you can't belittle these ideas
when i look back on what it was like
being a kid having a friend who would
call people names it felt like he was
taking the power away from it he would
say something that was ultimately
meaningless to all of us and was meant
ingest and kind of playfully so we never
got mad about it
nowadays they've empowered it so much
that even asking someone to grab you a
burger is like the epitome of racism
that it's everywhere always
and it's not the right it's the the woke
who claim they're they're anti-racist
who are funneling as much oxygen into
those fires of racism as possible yeah i
wonder is it biological like is it in
the diet in the plastics in the water
the micro plastics and the it's a big
leap all these chemicals like that are
making people so tense and edgy that
they can't like not get angry when they
hear these things
i think a lot of it's just sort of
ideology going around it's it's making
people
you know mentally ill in a way that
their social media man yeah it's a lot
of it's social media a lot of it's
clicks
um a lot of people are staying at home
they just don't have their friend's
circle i mean this is the stuff like
jonathan height greg lucky enough wrote
about and cuddling the american mind um
yeah we're seeing all all-time highs of
of sort of mental health issues
uh
depression um sexlessness among young
kids not young kid well
college-aged people um i'd hope
sexlessness and young kids but uh yeah i
mean it's it's there's this skyrocketing
rates of mental health issues and this
is i think we're seeing sort of a
manifestation of a lot of that uh we
have this focus on these
these microaggressions so when i was in
in graduate school i remember hearing
from this
this other grad student was a black
woman and she was talking about how she
had this insane interaction that was
very racist she played ultimate frisbee
and
we were like what was this incident and
she had just started playing ultimate
frisbee in this new league but she was
very athletic and so she did really well
on the first time that she played
ultimate frisbee and so some friends
after the game came up to her they had
never met her before and they said man
you're so good at ultimate frisbee have
you ever played before and she's like no
and then someone else said well that's
just good genes and she took that as
being an instance of you know this
microaggression because oh i'm black i
have these good genes and i hear this
story remember thinking no the first
instinct was have you ever played before
have you practiced is that why you're so
good and she said no
and then so well what's the other
alternative
you're just have a predisposition you're
athletic you're a natural you're a
natural nature person and so she
dismissed the nurture part the practice
because she had never practiced before
and then because the the next available
option was you're a natural
athlete that was racism and i just
remember thinking this is completely
insane black people frank james all we
have been conditioned
to believe the highest level of our
existence is being a victim and so we
look that's how you prove you're black
i'm a victim
and so for that woman to prove her
blackness she's on a college campus i
would imagine she was a grad student
grad student on a college campus she's
lived a very privileged life there's
probably black people that tease her she
talks too good in english she's too
smart blah blah blah and so her way of
expressing her blacks
boy you wouldn't believe the racist [ __ ]
i went through oh someone at ultimate
frisbee said i was a natural
boom that's how she proves she's black
you know you wanna know what's crazy
i experienced racism in my life in fact
we had a guest on the show i don't wanna
bring up his name let him keep his keep
his peace for the time being and when i
said i understand your your your worries
about racism you know my family dealt
with some of this stuff he said no you
didn't you're lying you're a white boy
and i'm like okay so like if i agree
with you now i'm wrong i don't think i
think a lot of it is just power it is
this fascistic ethos of there is no
truth but power this guy is clearly not
on my side he doesn't like what i have
to say so when i reach out and say i
understand that because i've experienced
similar it's denial and rejection no
you are wrong it couldn't have happened
to you and i'm like that's just the
weirdest thing to me you try to relate
to someone and say i can understand your
argument and they just they basically
spit in your face yeah if i was like
slap your mom i really like your skin
color man you have really nice skin
color like i don't hear that compliment
going around a lot but you can complete
someone's bone structure you got really
nice cheekbones i was told this today so
i had to get makeup for the daily wire
oh boy they do this thing where they're
like uh they're very polite about it
they go uh would you want to do any
touching up any you know makeup cause i
got like a blemish in there and i was
like i'm good i think it's fine like you
sure just a little bit i mean it's a big
deal and i was like
if you guys think it's it's it's i need
it they're like no no it's fine
we might as well right you know trying
to be polite about it but every camera
needs a nail but you know what you know
what the makeup artists always say
maybe it's just true for me they say you
have great skin no i imagine they say to
everybody because they're doing makeup
and they got to say that to you and did
i go excuse me what does that mean are
you talking about the color
no i'm just like hey okay you know
whatever
let me ask y'all a difficult question
this is a i think it because it'd be
difficult to be this transparent but i'm
this is the tim pool show you guys are
really transparent
as
untim i know you're not white per se but
do you have trepidation
in dealing with black people you don't
know
because you you anything you say can and
will be potentially used against you
does that thought cross your mind you
know coming in and talking to me it's
like you watch my show you know my
reputation oh i can be myself it's
whitlock but when you're dealing with
perhaps someone black that you don't
know do you
sit there and think like oh my god let
me be very careful no not after i see
their eyes the we are the brain eyeballs
spinal cord creature holding these
moving these
these salt water bodies around you just
look in the eyes man it's not that we're
all the same i used to say that a lot
but it's like
i i don't even like that all the color
and the shape fades away when you're
communicating with someone
and and they everybody appreciates it
that's been my ethos since
since i was like 14
at least since i was two you know really
when i was 26. you know what it is for
me
it's politics not race
when when you know
there's that study i think i was out of
yale we talk about quite a bit where
conservatives speak to black people
normally but liberals
like dumb down their language
which is the it's insane
i couldn't imagine doing that and so uh
you know for me
i'm like
i i really just kind of talk to
everybody the way i talk to everybody i
might have uh
i i think it's fair to say there are
certain assumptions we might make about
people based on race based on the
politics of the env of our environment
but i would say 99.9 percent is just
like
i'm gonna talk to this person the same
way i talk to everybody else because i
don't want to make assumptions about
them yeah first especially based on
we're not different races we're the same
species the homo sapien and i like
talking to people with different ethnic
ethnic backgrounds or like different
genetic backgrounds because our
ancestors lived in different
environments like the asian ancestry
maybe because the winds were so biting
in the mongolian plains they squinted
and over generations the babies were
just born so they didn't have to squint
you know or people with darker skin than
mine uh had a lot of sunlight people
with light skin like my ancestors lived
at night everybody has darker skin my
dad one time i was at the beach and my
dad was like we lost ian where's he and
they looked down the beach they saw a
glowing white thing there he is
right
here here's what i think is is important
to understand especially like when it
comes to race uh there's there's
different uh second like physical
characteristics uh say hair for instance
there's different hair products for
white and black people or not even
necessarily white and black but you know
there literally are different uh hair
treatments and styles
so there's there's an assumption someone
might make but it shouldn't change these
things don't change the way you treat a
human being's their their soul their
theirs their spirit i wonder about this
because you know when we talk with
people like sheamus of freedom tunes for
instance
and you know he very much believes in
the soul and the body as being one
i'm like is it is it something that
people who don't believe in a soul will
treat you like nothing but the body and
ignore your inner you know what i mean
you know what i don't like they'll look
at you and think your race is you
instead of wondering about who you are
as a person because you have a soul i
don't like when i talk to people about
people with dark skin if i'm talking
about the difference of light skin and
dark skin because it's relative to my
skin color and that's really rude of me
to act like that like i should be
talking about people with light skin
and and just see it from other
perspectives than me is like the zero
point as the starting point well let me
uh i don't know if you wanted to answer
that because i don't want to
no i mean i like to think i give people
you know the first volley in a
conversation and is going to be the same
for just about everybody
that i interact with and you know over
iterations that's when i'll build a sort
of a model but there's like hold on i
want to i want to throw the question
back at you jason do you think you or do
you think
black people have a certain way of
talking with white people in like a
similar fashion you asked us
in this culture today no i don't think
there's any trepidation any fear
uh because i think the culture has kind
of said there are no standards for black
behavior have you have you seen the ami
horowitz video on um voter id
i
think i have i didn't mean to interrupt
you so if you want to finish that
thought real quick no go ahead so uh you
know they say voter id is racist yeah
classic video i love bringing it up so
he goes to berkeley and he asks these
young white progressives is voter id
racist and what do they say of course he
says why he gets a few answers black
people can't afford ids black people
don't know where the dmv is and black
people don't have the internet so he
goes to the bronx he goes to harlem and
he asks this woman he's like ma'am it
might be he's a black woman he's like
this might seem strange but do you have
an id and she goes what
i know it might seem strange and she
goes of course i have an id he's like
okay he asks a young young black man
he's like
this i know i know my team's strange do
you know anybody who doesn't have the
internet and he's like what do you mean
12 year old kids know how to get dinner
we got in on our phone but my favorite
interaction
is when he walks up to this like older
black dude and he goes
do you know where the dmv is he goes
yeah it's right over on 25th he turned
it like he's giving him directions and
i'm just like
for for the media to push this narrative
about black people it's like have you
ever talked to a black person the
assumption that they're a different and
foreign group of people to me is is
mind-boggling what i don't but it plays
right into that yale study i was just
talking yeah i don't like black and
white i don't like the words because
first of all my skin's not white it's
like pinkish your skin's not black it's
like brown red you know and like
historically white magic is like healing
magic and black magic is like dark arts
like
so like it's the stigmas attached to
okay calling people black and white when
we're not hold on i gotta i gotta push
back because that is a woke argument
where they're trying to claim that like
harry potter and magic the gathering are
racist
white and black as a reference to night
and day exactly it's not great in the
daytime you can see the predators coming
and at night you can't so there's this
inherent like scariness to the dark
knight you know so like i don't like
that people use black and white i don't
like black
obviously
then stop playing magic the gathering
because black and white magic i'm a
white mage through and through that's
just gonna like to heal people i get
where you're coming from because the
word black bald like black has the
negative connotation and which is
arguing is like jason's not even black
why are we calling him black
i'm not really white why i get that but
but because we've established these
cultural customs that we all somewhat
adhere to
uh you know we got to live in this
reality do we i want to shatter that i
agree i i think you're 100 right we that
should be the goal i think we should be
literally trying to live up to dr king's
dream judge people by the content of the
character the left seems to be taking us
the total opposite direction and we now
all have again what you're seeing with
black people is that they interpret the
world through this lens of race every
interaction and it's like hey man
some people just having a bad day it had
nothing to do with your skin color
their wife may have made them sleep on
the couch last night and so he's grumpy
and gave you a cold answer it it and so
but we escape anything that bad if if
if he punched me in the arm right now
i could oh he only did that because i'm
black that may be his way of greeting
everybody that he's
friendly with or finds you know
interesting or whatever
but we just describe race and some
negative connotation to any experience
we have thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you